yesterday we
did a draft of the teams that didn't
make it to the playoffs last year most
likely to make it this year now we're
going to flip it around
teams that made it last year most likely
to miss this year the problem is there's
seven spots
per conference so this dynamic of half
the playoff field being
thrown out it's gonna change especially
when we go from six
to seven in this first year of the
expansion so with all that said
let's give it a shot i get the first
pick because yesterday
the trivia question was about a team you
were actually on so yeah uh
what color is blue it is blue that's a
trivia question
i got it right yes i'm gonna go
philadelphia eagles
nine and seven a year ago yeah and won
the division
barely they were five and seven at one
point had to win four in a row draw the
inside straight to somehow
get to the postseason still had to hold
off the giants week 17
after beating the cowboys week 16 and
all those injuries
already lining up for the eagles if any
of the teams who made it last year
isn't going to get back this year the
eagles are going to be at the top of the
list
yeah i understand that i mean i wrote
them down here as well i i get that and
you're right the way it's already
shaping up with the injuries and things
it's that's a little scary right now uh
in philadelphia
i'm gonna go with your minnesota vikings
you're mean my first pick all right
uh yep gotta go there again you know
again i think it's just
minnesota a little bit too much changing
over the roster and it's one of those
years where they don't make it they make
it every other year last year they made
it this will be here they don't but
i just think i look at no everson
griffin new pieces in the secondary hey
we're talking about the offensive line
issue earlier today
stefan digsby and gone you know
stefanski gone
uh you know kubiak totally taken over
there
uh i i just feel like this is a team
that's in a slight transition here
to make another push for a new team here
going into the future so
i'll go with the vikings is that team
for me yeah
i was thinking about them i i want to
flip to the afc though and i hate to say
this because you and i both love desean
watson because he is so freaking awesome
yeah but
you know the team around him may not be
and
they blew a 24 point lead in kansas city
last year
and got blown off the field blown off
the field
and if they have something like that
happen to them again
to start the season it's hard to avoid
having that what's the point vibe
because they know what's waiting for
them at the end of the day
if they make it to the playoffs they're
crossing paths at some point
with the chiefs unless they get lucky
and the ravens or someone else beat the
chiefs ahead of time
but to to be humiliated on a national
stage
to end last season and to potentially
have it happen again
to start the next season i i
of of the teams in the afc they're the
most likely to not make it back
in part also the colts are going to be a
lot better we pegged them yesterday as a
team to make it back right the titans
are still the titans yeah
uh i i think that that of the teams in
the afc and given that there are seven
spots the most likely to fall out of
those seven spots is the text
i i i get you there i do i mean i i do
there's i have concerns about them too i
i think my biggest concern is i think
it's gonna be just
it's gonna be all about the offense it's
gonna be all about desean watson and
throwing the football and
i just wonder if it'll be too much
pressure on him i think the offense
could have a great year
i question a defense that was 28th in
football last year
and didn't do anything this offseason to
make themselves better
except really get a little bit older so
you know i just look at it from that
aspect that's a big question mark for me
you know and i just don't know if they
can hold up so i get you there with that
pick
we didn't even mention this no deandre
hopkins right which puts more pressure
on deshaun watson and they're putting a
lot of eggs
in the david johnson basket that he's
going to go back to the guy that he was
three years ago yeah
exactly you know and again i i think
that the andre hopkins thing in some
ways can be a blessing in disguise for
the offense and all of that
but i don't know if i just believe yeah
i feel like they're a team right now
that i look at and go
i think they're gonna have to score a 30
plus every week to win football games
all right tennessee titans are going to
be my next one a little bit for the
logic you kind of just mentioned
you know first off they're in a good
division the colts are good you gotta
deal with
uh you know desean watson but they were
a nine and seven football team last year
you know and again we could question
whether they would have been better if
they moved to tana hill earlier and all
that but
also i go hey the style of football in
which they play
can lead to some close football games
yeah they want to run the ball play
through the defense
strike down field do things like that
and my big thing is a year of everybody
studying arthur smith's offense
you know derek henry in the run game oh
if that kind of hits a slow start
here early in the year and who's going
to be that next guy to show up on the
offense that's a dangerous weapon in the
past game we know it's aj brown
who's the next guy is joe new smith
going to show up is corey davis going to
show up
so i'll go with the titans uh and uh and
them for this one
can i just pass there's no way that i
can pick a team
now no right yeah then i cuz
but i gotta go no i'm not passing i i'm
just kidding i'll go green bay packers
i i i they were 13 and three and it felt
like they weren't as good as 13 and
three and with the jordan love thing
unless there really is a full-blown
aaron rodgers revenge tour it may be
hard for them to get back
yeah i okay i hear you uh damn
i mean it that does there's really not a
team i want to pick here that i believe
that i can't be in it i want to pass as
well
i think about and i think if i look at
the teams though
i think the net the one up i'll go with
buffalo if i got to pick one other team
here all right
and i don't believe it but i'm picking
them because that's what the draft is
but
you know i don't know what josh josh
allen gets
loose with the football and has a lot of
turnovers and things like that but don't
tell me all right
we'll apply all the caveats look we had
to have six
right these are the most likely to miss
but we understand that that
most if not all of them can still make
it yeah just have to pick somebody at
this point
the 49ers crossed my mind when i think
back to how close they came to being the
number five seed they have a little
super bowl hangover
a lot of energy doesn't step up yeah
you never know what's going to happen it
wouldn't be the first time a team that
lost the super bowl didn't make it back
to the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports